- Good afternoon everybody,
Peter Salovey, President
Peter Salovey and all.
Welcome to the second of this year's
Tanner lectures on human values
by Achille Mbembe, professor at the
University of the
Witwatersrand in Johannesburg
and at the Wits Institute
for Social and Economic
Research at that University.
Quick introduction today,
we don't stand on too much
formality on the second
day of the Tanners.
Remember please that
we will reconvene here
tomorrow morning at
10:30 for the final event
of this year's Tanners and
that is a panel discussion
among Professor Mbembe and Yale professors
Inderpal Grewal and Michael Denning.
I was in a funny conversation
a couple of days ago
with Achille and Michael about those
occasions where you give a talk and then
someone stands up afterwards to
summarize it and you think to yourself
did I really talk about that?
So I won't today take
the risk of summarizing
Achille's lecture from yesterday
but only signal a few of his themes,
remind you of a few of its themes
and hope that he might
recognize the signals
as something he did indeed talk about.
We learned yesterday
about the new mobility
regime of the lectures
title and its implications
for the changing nature of borders
and their effects in our world.
We heard about the border as a zone of
securitization and control
and about three different
approaches to theorizing
this zone, approaches that characterized
those against whom the border is mobilized
in terms of precarity,
in terms of extreme vulnerability,
of detention, incarceration, violence.
But we also had a glimpse
of something more hopeful,
a border as a place even of rescue
and we heard finally, fascinatingly
and at some length about
an existential flip
by which the features of
borders at land and sea
have been exchanged.
The fluidity of sea borders
described, theorized, made almost mythic
by Carl Schmitt has now been transferred
to land borders.
This has happened because we
live in that mobility regime
of Achille's title.
The medium of land
borders is no longer land
but has become a fluid medium
and what does this medium consist of?
The tens of millions of
displaced human bodies
defining new border zones
by their movements, zones then
not limited to liminal spaces
but extending everywhere
those movements reach.
This might also look like
a hopeful development
and perhaps we will see how
it is so in today's lecture
entitled The Idea of a Borderless World.
But not so fast, because Achille was quick
to remind us that in the
era of digitized biometrics
and securitized borders
even the fluid motions
of millions can be tracked and controlled.
We will find out, Achille.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you very much Gary.
I indeed recognize myself
in the brilliant summary
of this lecture you have just given us.
I would also like to thank
the president of the university, Peter,
who is with us this evening.
Yesterday I intimated that
the government of mobility
might well be
one of the most important problems
to confront the world
during the first half
of the 21st century.
The capacity to decide who can move,
who can settle,
where and under what conditions
is increasingly becoming
the core of political struggles
over sovereignty,
over nationalism, citizenship, identity,
security and freedom.
I strongly suggested that with Western
colonial expansion and more decisively
with the advent of capitalism,
the raison d'etre of the border
is to attend to key questions
such as to whom does the earth belong,
who can lay what types of claims
to what parts of it,
and to raise beings who inhabit them,
who determines its
distribution or partition?
In framing the question
of the border in this way
I was trying to show that the power
of the border lies
in its capacity to regulate
what are called the multiple distributions
of populations and by population I mean
humans and non-humans.
Their distribution on
the body of the earth
and in so doing to affect the vital forces
of all kinds of beings.
I also argued that as
the 21st century unfolds
a global renewed desire from both citizens
and their respective states
for a tighter control
of mobility is evident.
Indeed wherever we look, the
drive is towards inclusion
or in any case towards an
intensification of the dialectics of
territorialization and
deterritorialization,
the dialectics of opening and inclusion
The belief that the world would be safer
if only risks ambiguity and uncertainty
could be controlled and if only identities
could be fixed once for all and secured,
that belief is gaining momentum
and risk management techniques
are increasingly becoming a means
to govern mobilities.
Such techniques are indeed proliferating.
In particular
I highlighted the extent to which,
as Gary was reminding
us, the biometric border
is extending into multiple realms
not only of social life but of the body
that body are called the
body that is not mine.
Tonight, I would like to pursue
this line of argument concerning the
redistribution of the earth
not only through the
control of bodies but also
through the control of movement itself
and its corollary speed which indeed is
what migration control
policies are all about,
controlling bodies but
also movement itself
and its corollary speed.
More specifically I would
like to see whether,
and under what conditions,
we could re-engineer
the utopia of a borderless Africa
and by extension a borderless world
since as far as I know
Africa is part of the world
and the world is part of Africa.
I would like to do that,
taking into consideration
the contemporary matrix of flows, closures
and circulations including the circulation
of various forms of capital.
Now you will ask me
but why is it important
to attend once again to
what is obviously a utopian intent,
the question of a borderless world?
I think it's important
for a number of reasons.
The first which is, let's
say, a philosophical reason
is that from its inception
movement or more precisely borderlessness
has been central to
various utopian traditions.
When you look at the
very concept of utopia
that is what it refers to,
it refers to that which has no borders,
beginning with the imagination itself.
I think the power of utopianism
resides in its ability to instantiate
the tension between borderlessness,
movement and place.
A tension, if we look carefully, that has
marked social transformations
in the modern era.
This tension continues in
contemporary discussions
of movement based social processes
particularly international migration,
open borders, transnationalism
and even cosmopolitanism.
When you read Kant on cosmopolitanism
Kant's discourse on cosmopolitanism is
traversed from one end to
the other by this tension
between borderlessness,
place and movement.
So it seems to me that in this context
the idea of a borderless
world can be a powerful
albeit problematic resource for
social, political and even
aesthetic imagination.
The second reason is that
precisely because of the current atrophy
of the utopian imagination,
apocalyptic imageries and narratives
of cataclysmic disasters
and unknown futures
have colonized the spirit of our times.
We find them everywhere,
in popular culture, in
political discourses, in cinema,
in music, they're everywhere.
Indeed, some of the ecological anxieties
and fantasies of the apocalypse
I would argue are the
product of the Anthropocene
but what politics do visions
of future catastrophe
engender if not a politics of separation
rather than a politics of the humanity
as species coming into being
as stewards of the earth?
Because we inherited history in which
the consistent sacrifice of some lives
for the betterment of others is the norm
and because these are times
of deep-seated anxieties
including anxieties of racialized others
taking over the planet,
because of all of that
racial violence is increasingly encoded
in the language of the border
and in the language of security.
As a result, contemporary
borders are in danger
of becoming sites of reinforcement,
reproduction and
intensification of vulnerability
for stigmatized and dishonored groups,
for the most racially marked,
the ever more disposable,
those that in this era of
a neoliberal abandonment
have been paying the heaviest of prices
for the most expensive period
of prison construction in human history.
Refer to the prison here
precisely to the casual landscapes
of a world
precisely as the antithesis of movement,
of freedom of movement.
Is no dramatic opposite
of the idea of freedom
of movement than prison
and the prison is
key feature
of the landscapes of our times.
So in proposing to reexamine
the question of a borderless Africa
and a borderless world
I would like to stay away
from dominant ways in which
this issue has easily been dealt with.
That is, under the sign of Kant
and his promise of
unbounded cosmopolitanism,
and I would likely stay away from
the other dominant
approach to the question
of a borderless world,
one under the sign of
liberal individualism
understood as an antidote
or to the deeply
ingrained fascist impulses
of European governments and bureaucracies.
Referring yesterday at dinner with Gary
to a very important chapter in
Arendt's important classic book,
The Origins of Totalitarianism.
As chapter two it's called
Race and Bureaucracy.
The reference I have just made
alludes to indeed that chapter,
which as I was signaling
for some unknown reasons
has not really been
the object
of major consideration.
So for those of you who
are looking for a topic
for your dissertation
there's one right there.
Chapter two, The Origins
of Totalitarianism.
So I would like to stay
away from these two modes of
approaching the question
of a borderless world.
Both of them, in fact,
though they seem to be worlds apart
have something in common.
They both
articulated around a concept
you might hopefully know of,
the concept of the fourth freedom.
In classical liberal thought
there are three core freedoms
First of all
freedom of movement,
and within freedom of movement,
movement of of capital of course,
priority number one
cause there is no capital without goods.
The freedom of movement of goods
and more and more especially
in these times of ours,
number three, services,
freedom, movement of those
who can provide services.
Those are the three freedoms,
the three core freedoms.
So the concept of the fourth freedom
has to do with the movement of persons.
So traditional engagements
with the idea of a borderless world
aim at precipitating
the advent of that fourth freedom
which is freedom of movement of persons
and within that configuration
a borderless world would
look something like this.
It would be a world of free movement,
of capital, of goods, services and persons
and such movement, such
freedom of movement
would not be restricted to the core,
economically rich countries or states,
which is the case as we speak.
That the Schengen system, for instance,
is limited to the core European countries.
In fact, if you have an
American passport you can basically go
wherever you want.
The world belongs to you.
But this is not the case for
every inhabitant of our planet.
So in the configuration
I have just referred to,
the fourth freedom,
the ability to move around the planet
would no longer limited,
to put it crudely,
to Europeans and to Americans.
It would be a radical right
that would belong to everybody
by virtue of each and every individual
being a human being.
So it's a right that would be
extended including to
poor members of the earth.
So you see we go back to
this question of the earth.
There would be no visas,
meaning in some let's say instances
of the fourth freedom movement
there would be no visas,
there would be no quotas,
there wouldn't be any
bizarre category to fill.
First of all because you
wouldn't have to apply
for a visa so wouldn't
have to fill anything.
There would be no application
procedures preceding any move
which means that one
could just get on a plane,
on a train, on a boat, on the road,
on a bike, rights of non-discrimination
would be extended to all.
So a borderless world
would be the world in which
circulatory and pendulum migrations
would be the norm with in fact longer term
settlements less likely since borders
would be easy and open.
I will give you one little example
please when I was growing up,
I mean not so long ago,
don't don't believe Gary when he says
we met 25 years ago.
We did but we were both very, very young.
(audience laughs)
So not so long ago I was born in Cameroon.
Cameroon used to be a German protectorate
which became after the First World War
divided between the
winning powers, England on the one hand
and France on the other.
I was born in the French part of Cameroon
and until the beginning of the 80s
it was possible to travel to France
with one's identity card,
national identity card.
Most people went to France and came back.
They didn't go there because
they wanted to settle there.
Most people want to
live where they belong,
quote unquote,
but they want to be able to come and go
and they are more likely to come and go
when the borders are
not hermetically closed.
So the borderless world imagined by
the fourth freedom movement
is premised therefore on these
rights of non-discrimination
and on this circulatory and pendular
set of migrations.
Now let me move on
I wanna go further into
those debates,
they are both complicated
and quite straightforward.
We have those who support
free movement of labor and those who
believe that it only intensifies
levels of exploitation,
especially of migrants,
we can talk about it
during the discussions.
What I really want to do now
is to still in this attempt at
elucidating or posing differently
the question of a borderless world,
what I would like to do is to
contrast two paradigms.
On the one hand
examine the liberal idea
of a borderless world
through the
free movement
let's say concept.
So contrast it with African pre-colonial
understandings of movement in space.
That's what I want to do
in the hope that in contrasting these
two paradigms we might begin to
let's say this will
give us conceptual resources to expand
on this utopian project,
project of a borderless world.
When I say liberal classical thought
of course it is extremely complicated,
you understand that,
I don't have the time to go into
all the nuances, I'm giving you a kind of
archetype which needs to be itself
properly deconstructed.
And here I will rely in particular
on a recently published work called
Movement and the Ordering of Freedom.
Just keep in mind that idea
of the ordering of freedom.
It's a work has been published by
Hagar Kotef, an Israeli
scholar who teaches
at the School of Oriental
and African Studies in London
and you might
let your imagination work and understand
why it is that it's an Israeli who is
let's say interested in this.
So what Hagar shows in that work
is the extent to which liberal thought,
liberal political thought, has in fact
always been saddled with a
contradiction when it comes to imagining
the possibility of a borderless world.
And her argument is that
this contradiction which
I will elicit in a moment
stems from its conception of movement.
She shows that, in fact,
two dominant configurations of movement
constantly come into
conflict with each other,
the terms cancel each other,
within classical liberal thought.
Movement here
is seen both as a manifestation of freedom
and as an interruption of order,
as a threat to order,
and one of the functions of the state
is therefore,
to craft a concept of order
and stability
and security that is reconcilable
with its concept of freedom
and its concept of movement.
That is the the contradiction
and to some extent, Hagar argues,
the liberal classical state is the enemy
of people who restlessly move around.
Why, because such people are configured
as an in-assimilable authority,
you cannot assimilate them.
They are constantly on the move
and in fact there are career
repercussions of all of this.
I mean when colonialism sets
foot in Africa for instance,
the biggest problem of the colonial state
in the continent of Africa
from the 19th century on
is to make sure that people
stay in the same place.
It has a hard time
bringing them to stay in the same place
because the state believes
that they are constantly
on the move.
They are, quote unquote, uncaptured
so the business of a state is
how to capture them because why
do you want to capture them?
You want to capture them precisely because
without capturing them
sovereignty doesn't mean anything.
Sovereignty means you capture people,
you capture a territory,
you delimited borders
and this allows you in turn to exercise
the different types of
monopolies Max Weber spoke about,
a monopoly over of course territory,
a monopoly over the people,
monopoly in terms of the
use of legitimate force
and very importantly
because everything else
depends on that monopoly over taxation.
But you can't tax people
who have no address,
today here,
tomorrow morning they're
going for (mumbles)
and next week they have moved
to a different entirely location.
So the state sees such people as enemies
both of freedom because
they abuse freedom,
they don't exercise it with restraint
and enemies of security and order.
You can't build an order on the basis of
that which is unstable.
So that's a very important aspect
of, let's say, what
classical liberal theory
tells us about movement.
The same state is a friend
of self regulated movement.
Why, because freedom is here understood
as being about moderation.
It's about self-regulation,
it's not about excess.
Excessive movement immediately
conjures problems of security
and bad movement is seen as a threat
and I quote Hagar, "freedom
is only politically valuable
if it relies on some mechanisms
that regulate the movement
that manifests it."
I quote her quoting Hobbes.
So as Kotef argues,
movement not only had to be restrained
via an array of disciplinary mechanisms,
it had to be reconciled with freedom
and to some extent self restraint,
but the ability to restrain oneself
or to regulate oneself was not assumed
to be the share of all subjects.
That is not everybody who is able to
restrain himself or herself
and some movements were
therefore configured as
freedom and others were deemed improper,
and were conceived as a threat.
That's the bifurcation we have
in classical liberal thought
and what point is it that
a specific kind of movement
by specific kinds of subjects
is or is not a threat.
That's the spectrum that haunts
classical liberal states from those years
up to now.
We haven't got rid of that spectrum.
So the way in which
classical liberal states
have tried to resolve this contradiction
has been by putting forward
the idea of managed mobility
which, by the way, is back on the agenda.
Right now as I speak, in Europe
and even in South Africa
I've been doing some work
with the Department of Home Affairs
on recalibrating inter African migrations.
The key concept is managed mobility.
So within the framework
of managed mobility
and because of the perceived
aberrant movements,
certain categories of the population
are constantly seen as posing a threat
not only to themselves,
to their own security but also to others,
other security and such a threat,
it is thought, can be diminished
if their movements are confined
and if they are domesticated
and subject to some form of other reform.
And this is not new in fact.
This has been typical indeed
of the ways in which
different figures of mobility
historically have become the foundation
upon which different modes of governance
were produced.
In the West, generally taken,
one such board of governance
has consisted in
instituting what is called
a racial border, that
you have physical borders
but you also have a racial border.
Such was the case under colonialism,
such was the case of
course in slave owning
and settler colonial societies.
In all those places where settler liberty
and freedom of movement required
the criminalization of countless others
and such instances of criminalization
and stigmatization became indispensable
features of liberal government.
I could go on and on on that
but let me move on.
We can pick it up during the discussion.
Let me just capture what I have tried
to say in one or two sentences
just for you to be able to keep in mind
because now I'll be moving on
and contrasting this model
with the African pre-colonial model.
So in the classical liberal
model I was referring to,
security and freedom
precisely because of the racial border,
which some of us are
particularly interested in,
security and freedom came to be defined
as a right of exclusion.
Order within that model
is about securing the
unequal ordering of property
relations, that's what it is,
and asserting the boundaries of the nation
goes hand-in-hand in that model
with the assertion of
the boundaries of race.
Now defining the boundaries of race
within that model requires
a proper definition
of the boundaries of the body,
as I was arguing is the,
thus the centrality of the body
in the calculus of both
freedom and security.
Now,
let's look into
what are called the African model.
Here again it's a very
complex consolation.
For lack of time I will go straight to
what matters and then we
will disaggregate it later.
First of all,
let me say that pre-colonial Africa
might not have been a borderless world,
this in the sense in which we have been
defining borders since yesterday.
But where they existed,
borders were always porous
and permeable, that in fact
the business of a border is to be crossed.
That's what borders are for
but there is no border,
conceivable border,
outside of the principle,
the law of permeability.
I can give you countless
practical examples
to instantiate this,
but just believe me for the time being
that's how it was.
As evidenced by traditions
of long distance trade
circulation was fundamental.
It was fundamental in the production of
cultural forms, of political forms,
of economic and social
and religious forms.
The most important vehicle for
transformation and change
was mobility.
It was not class struggles in
the sense we understand it,
it was mobility.
Mobility was the motor of any kind of
social or economic
political transformation.
In fact it was the driving principle
behind the delimitation and organization
of space and territories.
So the primordial principle
of spatial organization
was movement, was continuous movement
and it is still part
of present-day culture.
To stop is to run risks.
You have to be on the move constantly.
More and more, especially
in conditions of crisis,
be on the move as a very
condition of your own survival
because if you are not on the move
the chances of survival are diminished.
So dominance, to dominate sovereignty
was not exclusively
expressed through the control
of territory, physically
marked with borders.
It was not.
Now you'll ask me but how was it then,
if you cannot control a territory,
how you can you exercise sovereignty?
How can you extract anything
since, as far as we know,
power expresses itself,
manifests itself also
if not primarily through
one or the other form
of extraction of something.
All of that was expressed
through networks.
Networks, crossroads for those of you
who are familiar with African literature.
the importance of roads and crossroads
in African literature is astounding.
Read Soyinka, read Chinua Achebe,
Amos Tutuola,
roads and crossroads are everywhere
in that literature.
So crossroads, flows of
people and flows of nature
both in dialectical relationship
because in those cosmogonies
people are unthinkable
without what we call nature.
So the realization, I mean the
Anthropocene term,
which seems to be a novelty
in parts of our world today,
we have always lived in that.
It's not new
because you cannot think of people
who are thinking of non-humans.
And here again, I mean read Tutuola,
it's a world of humans and non-humans
interacting, acting with others
what Latour and others have called
this rigid agency,
typical of those kinds
of let's say metaphysics
of the human and non-human.
Now I don't want to exaggerate this.
To be sure, fixed geographical
places such as towns
and villages did exist.
People and things could
be concentrated in a particular location
and such places could even become
the origin of movement
and there were links
between places, links such
as roads are mentioned then,
flight paths,
but places were not described
by points or by lines.
What mattered the most was
the distribution of
movement between places.
Movement was the driving force
of the production of
space and movement itself
if we were to believe
some of those cosmogonies
you have in mind,
the Dogon cosmogony that were
particularly studied by Marcel Griaule,
all other cosmogonies in equatorial Africa
dealt with by anthropologists
such as, and historians
such as Jan Vansina,
Jansen and others,
movement itself was not necessarily
akin to displacement.
What mattered the most
was the extent to which
flows and the intensities intersected
and interacted with other flows,
the new forms they could
take when they intensified.
So movement, especially among the Dogon,
could lead to divergence,
it could lead to convergence,
it could lead to intersections,
and convergence, divergence
and intersection were more
important than points.
They were more important than lines,
they were more important than surfaces,
lines, points and surfaces
as we know being cardinal reference in
Western geometrics.
So what we have here
is, let's say, a different
kind of geometry.
It's an entirely
different kind of geometry
out of which concepts of borders,
concepts of power, concepts of relations,
concepts of separation derive.
So the point is, if we want to
harness
alternative resources,
conceptual vocabulary type of that
to imagine a borderless
world here is an archive.
I'm not saying that is the only one
but what we have to
harness are the archives
of the world at large and
not only the Western archive
because in fact
in the Western archive
the Western archive
doesn't help us to develop
an idea of borderlessness.
The Western archive is premised on
the crystallization of
the idea of the border,
That we have to check later on,
I'm just saying it as a provocation.
So I could go on and on
on these alternative geometries.
Let me just add one or two things.
In this configuration, wealth and power
or let me say wealth in people
always trumped wealth in things.
Two forms of wealth,
you could be wealthy in
terms of your capacity
to agglomerate around you
clients, family members and so forth
and so on or you could be wealthy just by
virtue of having accumulated a huge
amount of quantity of things.
So you see here
the nexus of quantities and qualities,
qualities of persons,
categories of persons,
being at play here
and multiple forms of membership
were always available.
You would be astonished,
you take one society
and look into the dictionary
of forms of membership.
How is it that one belong?
Through what window is it
that you can enter the house?
Multiple forms of membership,
not a kind of rigid classification
where either you are a citizen
or you are a foreigner.
In between being a citizen
and being a foreigner
there was a whole repertoire
of alternative forms of membership.
And building alliances through trade,
marriage or religion,
incorporating newcomers,
refugees, asylum seekers
into existing policies,
that was the norm.
You dominate by integrating foreigners,
all kinds of foreigners,
and just to
add to what I've just said,
peoplehood, not talking about nationhood,
peaplehood included not only the living
but also the dead and the unborn,
humans and non-humans.
Exactly in line with all we are being told
about in this age of the Anthropocene.
And community was unthinkable
without some kind of foundational debt.
You know there are two, many,
but two principal forms of debt.
There is a kind of debt that is I would
say it's proprietary.
Kind of debt I mean banks,
some of us are in debt to banks.
Can you pay interest?
If you don't pay interest,
they wake up one morning
and the amount to pay for the interest has
overtaken the amount you
borrowed in the first instance.
So that form of debt
are called proprietary.
But in this constellation,
human constellation talking about,
there's a different kind of
debt that is constitutive
of their very basis of the relation
and it's a kind of debt that encompasses
not only the living, the now,
but also those who came before and those
who will come after us,
that we have obligations
to that chain of beings
which include, once again, not only humans
but animals, but what we call nature
and so forth and so on.
Okay I can come back to that if you want
to have further comments so
you see what I'm getting at.
So those are the two models once again,
these are archetypes.
They have to be properly historicized,
what are the social forces driving what,
what are the limits we
all understand that.
Where are we to today?
It seems to me that
worldwide, the combination of
fast capitalism and we
mention it yesterday
the saturation of the everyday
by digital and computational technologies,
these two things have led
to the acceleration of speed
and the intensification of connections.
In fact the world is so connected today.
Today basically you can sit where you are,
you have access to your technologies
and you have access to
an amount of knowledge
we have never had access to.
That is going on.
at the same time willful ignorance is
a feature of our times.
how come we know so less when
the amount of knowledge we have
has never been as astounding as it is?
Whatever the case, it
seems to me that ours
is in this regard
an era of planetary entanglement.
But this is not all,
as Paul Virilio, Virilio
is a French scholar,
but not only him countless
others have suggested,
the twin phenomenon of
immediacy and instantaneity
is presently one of the
most pressing problems
confronting us or in any case
one of the most determining factors
ushering a new technolopolitical epoch.
Since yesterday I have been
trying to bring in discussion
this event which is
our emergence into a new technological age
because we can't simply
understand what's going on
if we don't factor in this
new technological development.
So it seems to me that,
in line with Virilio and the others,
that one of the the most pressing
problems confronting us,
ushering us into this
new technopolitical epoch
has to do, indeed, with the twin phenomena
of instantaneity and images.
So in considering
what borders have become,
the kind of work they are doing
today, not yesterday, now
or in considering what a borderless world
or borderless Africa might look like
it might be useful to take seriously
the possibility that
real time now prevails
above both real space and
the geosphere in general.
And that's really the key argument
I would like to push tonight.
The supersession of
real space by real time.
Something that is made possible precisely
because of
this technopolitical event
that is driven by
all we have been referring
to since yesterday.
The primacy of real time,
of immediacy
and instantaneity over and above
space, over and above territory,
over and above surface,
might not yet be irreversible
but it is in the process of becoming
what we could call a fait accompli.
Even if we wanted to reverse it,
it might too late.
That's what a fait accompli is.
A fait accompli is also, by the way,
that which nobody can account for.
So question of unaccountability,
the impossibility to account for,
or the difficulty to
account for which means
the difficulty to take responsibility for.
In fact, of the three
main physical barriers
science teaches us barrier of sound,
of heat and light,
the first two have already been felled.
The sound barrier and
here I quote Virilio,
has been, "cut across by the super
"and hypersonic aircraft
while the heat barrier
"is penetrated by the rockets taking
"human beings outside the earth's orbit
"in order to land them on the moon."
But the third barrier,
still Virilio speaking,
that of light, "is not
something one can cross.
"You crash into it.
" It is precisely this barrier of time
which confronts history in
the present day," he adds.
So building on Virilio's remarks
we can argue that the moment humanity
will reach the light barrier,
that is the speed of light,
the historical event of
unprecedented importance
will happen,
which might throw history
itself in disarray
and might jumble up the
relation of the living beings
towards the world.
What do I mean by that?
By that I mean, when it happens
then we will have entered
a borderless world.
We'll enter a borderless world when,
let me put it differently,
when humanity reaches the light barrier
because territory
it won't vanish, it will still be there
but it will become irrelevant.
It'll become irrelevant
because precisely,
we will have finally
domesticated absolute speed
and having done so,
the earth will enter a new
period of its deep history,
one in which real time will
really have superseded real space.
So let me just say that
we are not yet there.
We might not get there in our lifetime,
some of us at least,
but take for instance
algorithmic trading,
also known as high-frequency trading.
Computerized, fully automated,
it is obvious that financial markets are
but one dimension of the ecology
of high-speed materiality
that is transforming not only
the nature of market access
in our time, but also, I should add,
the very nature of borders.
And in that sense it's not simply a
technological development.
So what I'm arguing for is that in order
to imagine a borderless world
we have to go beyond the liberal idea
of movement and speed and,
somewhat, draw from other archives.
I'll end all of this now by
putting on the table
a notion I take from the
Ghanaian constitution.
The Ghanaian constitution of Ghana
has developed a concept I haven't found
anywhere else.
It is the concept, a new right,
they call the right of a abode, A-B-O-D-E
as a fundamental right, that is
they want to add to the list
of traditional human rights.
It seems to me that this idea
of the right of abode
is a cornerstone for any real imagination
of Africa as a borderless space.
I say this because
if Africa is to contribute to
the unfolding global
debate on human mobility
in this age of territory entitlement
it needs to indeed
dig deeply into its own archives.
In a world in which arrest, detention
and incarceration, including at sea,
abandonment, deportation are seen as
the most efficient ways of dealing with
economic migrants,
refugees, asylum seekers
we should draw from our
own historical perspective,
experience as African and diasporic people
an articulate proposal for
ourselves and for the world
which is radically different
from the anti-humanist norms
and practices currently
prevalent on matters
concerning marginal human
mobility in the world.
I say this because at
the deep historical level
African diasporic struggles for freedom
and self-determination have always been
intertwined with the
aspiration to move and change,
whether under conditions of slavery,
Atlantic slavery, Trans-Saharan slavery,
under colonial rule
the loss of our sovereignty
automatically resulted
in the loss of our right to free movement.
This is the reason why
the dream of a free redeemed
and multi African nation,
what Marcus Garvey called
a bright star among the
constellation of nations,
this is why this dream has been
inextricably linked to
the recovery of the right
to come and go without let or hindrance
across our colossal continent.
In fact, our history in modernity
has been to a large extent
one of constant displacement
and confinement,
forced migrations and coerced labor.
Think of the plantation system
in the Americas and the Caribbean.
Think of the black codes,
the pig laws or the
vagrancy status after the failure
of reconstruction in the
United States in 1887.
Think of the chain gangs laboring attached
such as road construction, ditch digging,
tearing and deforestation
and so forth and so on.
Think too of the Code de L'Indigenat
in French colonial Africa,
of the Bantustans and labor
reserves in southern Africa
and of the Kaesong Industrial Complex in
today's United States of America.
In each instance, to be African
and to be black has meant to be consigned
to one or the other of the
many spaces of confinement
modernity invented.
The scramble for Africa
in the 19th century
and the carving of its
boundaries along colonial lines
turned the continent into
a massive castle space
and each of us into a potential
illegal migrant, unable to move except
under increasingly punitive conditions.
As a matter of fact, entrapment became
the precondition for the exploitation of
our labor which is why the struggles
for emancipation and
racial upliftment were
so intertwined with the struggles for
the right to move freely.
So if we want to
conclude the work of decolonization
we have to bring down colonial
boundaries in our continent
and turn Africa into a
vast space of circulation
for itself, for its descendants
and for anyone who wants
to tie his or her fate
with our continent.
That's the importance of the concept
of the right of abode
as written in the Ghanaian constitution.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
- [Man] We have time for some questions.
If you have a question
please go to the mic
on your side (mumbles).
- [Audience member] So you
talk eloquently about the
importance of movement without visas
and without, you know, any
kind of application process
and it's very moving to
think of it in those terms,
you know in terms of the
traditional constitution of Africa
as the casual space but at the same time
you also talk about the importance of
indebtedness, that we're indebted
to the debt and to some extent we're also
indebted or we can be held answerable
to to the future, to our descendants.
It seems to me that the two actually point
in slightly different directions
in the sense that being
indebted or acknowledging
that we are, that
somebody else will hold us
in their debt, whatever,
that one form or another,
either forward looking or backward looking
that puts us in a kind of a sequel
in which we do occupy a space
that cannot be freely relinquished.
So I just wonder if you could
comment a little bit about
the sense of unbounded
mobility on the one hand
and the sense of being obligated and being
held by our obligation,
which implies a certain
kind of constraint.
- Should we take a few questions, Gary?
Okay, take two.
- [Audience member] So my
question pertains a little bit
to the porous borders.
In some cases it does seem that
there are regimes or
arrangements where borders
are becoming more porous
but the exchange is
extreme surveillance and monitoring
and I can think of a few cases where
it's relatively easy to
enter various spaces,
countries, but the
exchange is that there's
better biometric information, as you
eluded to but also better surveillance,
whether it's monitoring
you via your phone,
via satellite, via drone
and I wonder if perhaps
one of the directions
that some of these
arrangements might be going in
is you can go wherever you want
but we're going to know
exactly what you're doing,
where you are, who you're meeting with.
So there's a freedom of
movement but there's no longer
really a freedom to anonymity
or to privacy, thanks.
- See I was,
I have my own convictions on each of
issues I put on the table.
I was, I can talk about that.
I was trying to
offer a way
in which we can recapture in these
times of utopian atrophy,
we can recapture the utopian resources
that are embedded in the idea of a world
that wouldn't have any border.
In particular a continent, for the reasons
I mentioned at the end,
that would become
really free for its people and
would speak to the world
from that position.
So that's the framework
I was trying to to build.
And of course,
as far as unbounded mobility is concerned
I think that it's a project we
have to take seriously.
We have to take it seriously
and whether or not it is
actually feasible.
In fact we have to hold dear onto it
precisely at the moment when it appears to
be totally utopian.
I argue in that way
for all kinds of reasons,
one of which has to do
with what I really believe is
our entry into a planetary age.
And this doesn't mean that
nation states don't exist
any longer, they are still there,
I'm not subscribing to the kind of
discourse of happy
globalization we witnessed
in the 90s when many believed
that in fact nation states
were going to disappear.
If anything they have
shown that they are extremely resilient
and they can mutate with the times.
So I have to hold on on to that
precisely because in
spite of their existence
none of the issues we
humanity is dealing with today
can result at a national level alone.
So I put forward this
renewal idea in the hope that
this renewed planetary consciousness
might force us to
address the questions I was
putting forward today,
whose earth is this?
Rather than whose country is this?
How do we distribute it, meaning not how
we conquer it for ourselves but meaning
how do we share it?
How do we share it
because sharing it is the very condition
of its sustainability?
At the moment when
the possibility of extinction
is real, it is plausible,
it's not implausible
so the question of
inhabitation of the world
at large, of the earth,
the question of sharing it as a condition
for its own durability
those questions become extremely important
especially if we want to move beyond
just an ethnographic description
of how borders work
and the kind of work they accomplish.
So if we want, the project is to inject
contemporary debates on
migration, movement, mobility
with the kind of
philosophical and theoretical
urgency that is made available to us
with the realization that we have
entered techno planetary age.
And then the questions of unboundedness
and obligation to locality it seems to me
they can be reshaped differently.
That would be a way of let's say
commenting on your comments.
You see on the one hand
if I limit myself to the continent
what we are really witnessing
is a double process, one of closure,
the other one of an
acceleration in terms of
opening of African borders.
Now there are 27
countries in the continent
where if you have an African passport
you can obtain your visa at arrival.
That wasn't the case
two or three years ago.
It's now the case.
Last week they signed in Kigali
a new treaty,
same kind of treaties you see everywhere,
NAFTA and the rest,
so they are moving in those directions,
want a free market for
the whole continent.
But as I was suggesting
it seems to me that the
most plausible way probably to
dismantle national
borders in the continent
might have to go through
domestication of new technologies.
I really believe that
paradoxically not that technologies
are neutral but
they are the the most direct way
in which colonial boundaries
in Africa will fall.
I can give you plenty of examples of
how it is already happening.
So on the one hand borders are becoming
a bit more porous than before
but on the other hand there is a global
drive to turn the continent into
a castle space.
Very few Africans
are welcomed as migrants
anywhere in the world.
You give me one example of
Africans arriving in any part of the world
where they are welcomed.
Europe in its attempt at reinforcing
its southern boundaries
is actively recruiting
the number of transit countries
in making sure that its
borders are extended
in the continent itself
but you can't have a situation
where people cannot go out
and they cannot circulate from within.
That double penalty is, it seems to me,
one of the biggest threats to
movement of people right now.
- [Audience member] I was
just listening to you today
and yesterday I was thinking about,
well I was reminded of one of Derrida's
deep frustration with Kant
and his frustration was that Kant
restricted his concept of cosmopolitanism
to the right of visitation and hardly ever
to the right of residence
and it seems to me that what is central
to your talk, what was
central to your talk today
and your talk yesterday
was the idea of moving freely
and I wonder if you could
perhaps talk a bit more about
the twin question of settling freely.
The right to settle freely
as opposed to move freely.
Settle, settle, settle, settle
Residence
- Oh residence
- As opposed to (laughs)
visit.
- Oh okay.
Okay, okay I see.
So settling as opposed to moving.
Frankly I don't know why I didn't
pay attention to
to settling.
Maybe because
of the antecedent
sedentary bias
that is my own bias
but I have a feeling that I mean
what we are all encouraged to do today
is just to settle.
Stay where, especially
stay where you are.
Just stay where you are, don't move around
and therefore I was not
interested in that part.
I haven't thought about it.
I don't think that is the problem today.
I don't know what do you think
but it seems to me that
we are all encouraged
to stay where we are,
not travel too much,
not settle as well
just be where we belong.
So the best way to shake that is to
look into the opposite which is
how do we make sure
that we move?
How do we make sure that
settlement is not the same as confinement
which it has been,
meaning some people's histories
in the plantation,
you quote unquote settle
and if you move
then it's an attempt,
it's a crime against property.
So I haven't thought about
it but I will think about it.
Yes.
- [Audience member] I
wanna to say thank you,
you've given us so much to think about
and powerful images for
thinking differently
about the world we're in.
Your account of Africa resonated very much
with our thinking about the Americas
where migrants are clamoring
for the right not to migrate as well as
the right to migrate and they link
the protection of mobility
to the possibility of restoration of home
and are also asking for something besides
the path to citizenship
as the means to achieve
and redeem themselves as
persons with protection and legal status.
So your critique of the
liberal framework about
freedom and security is very well taken.
My question is for the economics
a bit within this technology.
My work, recently I've been looking at
the use of x-ray
and the tracking and I think it goes to
this question about settling,
is that there is a category of people
who in the imagination
of this they are not
meant to live socially
right and in relation
but to be the surplus
who can be brought and left
so that along with immobility
is the forced migration and
the guest worker program
and the category of
existence in which they live
so long away from home
that they no longer have
that capacity of social
and relation or where
because they're incarcerated
the future growth
of their population in the U.S.
will be limited right,
where there's a bio-political
project around race.
But the work that I've
been doing with x-ray,
and I wanted to hear you
talk more about the body,
is an optic of state control
of looking inside the body
that is doing something different
from, it seems to me,
other regimes of race
and racial profiling.
You've said very powerfully
the way it travels with the person and
becomes part of the person's biography
and works against the
capacity of the person
to represent themselves
but it also, it seems
to me, is really again
linked to this production of an ideal
non-person who can be
made into a unit of work,
a unit of value
even as they're represented
in political discourse
as the refuse of nations,
as people who are
in their improper place or who are
surplus, do you know what I mean?
So there's the discourse that says
these are the surplus people, right,
who are improperly here
but they're being produced as non-persons
in the way statelessness
for an economic function
in ways that I'd love to hear
you maybe think about with me
because I hear very much
the the beautiful work
that you've done around the political
order of things I just wanted to ask you
to think the economic logic of that
border space a little bit more if you
get my question.
I have too many questions at once
I think is my problem (laughs).
- We can deal with some of them tomorrow.
Looking at Gary and Peter and the clock.
(audience mumbles)
(audience applauds)
(gentle music)